Chad's a a problem
um he can play he can dribble the ball
he can shoot the ball has great length a
great shot blocker he's only going to
get better you know and for a young guy
like that to have the field that he has
um you don't see many mistakes out of
him and I thought that was big you know
you you also you know him having last
year and being out but yet being able to
be around at his shows you know he he
does he's not making the typical
mistakes that a rookie would make and so
I think um you know the sky is the limit
for Chad uh you know we've watched him
for years leading up to him coming to
the NBA and always like yo this kid has
a chance and now we saw it tonight you
know he's going to be a problem for a
long time in this league